pick an opponent to eat a dog treat
lump it slump it my brothers don't eat
crumpets
lump it slump it my brothers don't eat
crumpets welcome everybody back to lv's
full fit roulette on standout tv the
objective of the show is to spin the
wheel wherever it lands on you have to
do a full fit and we've got two boxes
yeah in this box in my left hand is the
general knowledge questions and on the
right is the forfeits that's it
and now introducing the special guest we
have for you today t1 he's a content
creator also actor and artist
i was meant to do with that why is your
hand so wet bro
you're nervous in that i'm not nervous
all wet in there anyone's like tissue
you know what i'm nervous about i'm
nervous about you playing this game yeah
i'm nervous too so my name's t1 official
and obviously harry from standout and
alvi and my guys so they hit me up and i
turned up do you know what you're doing
today absolutely no idea and i'm on a
different level so just know i ain't
gonna take it easy on him yeah i'm just
letting him run out anyway and now
introducing the second guess his name
well tell him his name's a bit weird he
said take away the uh f on fish and put
an l in front of it which makes leash so
introducing the second contestant lish
he's saying
what are we saying what are you telling
me you're right yeah okay sure are you
prepared for today no right cool i'm
gonna just go straight into explaining
the rules guys my name's lish initially
i came here to be a runner i just wanted
to help i just wanted to give people
teas and coffees
and help make sure everyone's having a
good time but um yeah due to certain
circumstances someone didn't turn up and
now i'm in front of the camera dead dead
but it's all right with your neck stance
this is what
so basically you spin the wheel say for
instance it lands on
lish which should have been free he'll
put his hand into the box no it was free
butter you put your hands in this box
here the full fit box yeah and take out
one of these and then read it out loud
to all of us on the table and if you
don't want to do the forfeit you end up
getting one of those around the back of
your head i think you want one of those
no one wants to slap right lyric yeah if
it lands on number four on this table
which is random it's random box you go
into general knowledge general knowledge
simple so you know the rules then no i'm
just guessing
you'd be looking around the place i
think i handled the game quite well um
i'm lying i don't think i'm gonna handle
this very well
[Laughter]
you're number one you're number three
i'm two and four's there simple if you
don't do your forfeit you hold a
yeah simple as that yeah all right i
don't want to slap nobody i'm not your
father all right i'm not your parent no
further no do or do let's get on with
the
show
will i handle the game well
yeah i back myself i'm going to win
basically i'm going to win is there a
prize or is it just embarrassment
there's no prize
[Laughter]
am i
ready no
lump it slump it my brothers don't eat
crumpets
so cool who wants to go first i'll go
for it you sure yeah dude rock paper
scissors 100 you just want to go first
yeah all right well go ahead mate both
bam wait that one i'll pop a spin and it
landed what's this double spin is that
your oh
that's a definite two my guy cool
i don't even care blood i do care but i
don't care dm the last person yeah in
number three's dm saying oh number
freeze oh you
you're the guy now i've read it over
again i'll go get on your phone and see
that next man's a sneaker like okay
seamless they don't even have to land on
you for you to catch out get you out of
my cell phone
man don't try wait don't try it
don't try all the scooters
open
can you speak one more time huh now your
voice no no no no no no we're not doing
yes enough
i'm more nervous for you else just a
quick one sorry um to bother you right
now during the day probably busy didn't
work um just gotta send a message to you
from liz he's told me to let you know
that you're a snake and he knew it bye
bro that's pain i didn't want to do that
now you've got another kid
already you know i like that you got a
piece
of sweat automatically you deep so i've
done that i said i spoke to
i keep that under the forefit box for a
second wow
it's like
yeah and it is you i'm so happy as you
eat a garlic glove oh
stink ma don't get in the garlic man see
you see how these goofies go sometimes
it gets yourself or gets to have a guy
that's got him that one's lighter than
mine you can't even have no one today
your mat is in a small light
i'm telling you now garlic
i have to wear your mask what do you
[Music]
that drink there
man just wants anything yeah bang it
that's it quick
boom
gangster mode
i'd rather just do that you know that's
that's
not because that's it your mouse is
gonna stink all day that's it that's
that's about it oh smell it i can smell
it
am i smelling like i'm going off rat or
something some next kids do not try this
at home
which club did harry redknapp first
manage arsenal
your mouth smells you might have to stay
quiet for me there's no need to say that
don't say nothing i'm gonna say chelsea
yes
that's free right guys
there's your box it's peak still we're
going yes it might not be yeah
oh i'm scared eat two brussels sprouts
they're disgusting dry you know how hard
that is in your mouth big man ting
they're going to be very hard to eat
look at that
you can't eat them what are you doing
you can't be nailing the thing i didn't
either i didn't do all that you just
throw it in your mouth
put the two balls in your mouth oh my
god yes
you can't crunch you're gonna try crunch
but you can't crunch well i'm looking
dentist after this
oh i feel sick still you don't even
belch bro
this guy's letting that a whole lot of
steam i'm just lucky that i haven't
touched it
that's how you spin you man you know
free for free free don't you for free
you know a full fit boy let me spin that
one here hold that that's your business
i'm scared now don't be saying hold that
because it might be um
pick an opponent
to eat a dog treat oh my god please him
no because you know where you've been
i have been saying listen i'm saying
please please it's not gonna kill you
bro it's not gonna be killed man nothing
and i feel like z-ray's had you up like
he said the birmingham hits are coming
[Applause]
i got my whole life
he gave you the rough talk in your head
it said listen
i never said anything wow
i am telling everyone now who's watching
at home if it lands on any of these man
i'm not taking easy no more but i ain't
done anything to you you persuaded him
to give me this because i'm not a dog
bro i'm not a dog you know what i'm
upset i'm only going to take one i'm
bringing my mouth out oh my
days
bye keep me from
but good for dogs and then you've just
ate it my next time will be itchy when
you said that i was gonna grow a tails
that is the best spin you thought
the cheese the team sabotage
what currency is used in china yem it's
too easy though that's too you see it is
see you next time we write these
questions yeah
do these need to have
what currencies used in dubai in dubai
they're buying it
what about france france
yeah
no don't trade
that okay
don't do this i just try to bust you bro
i'm about to bust you no because that
will let you with me ask you anyway
yeah definitely a point on you yeah that
one's you that one
just food
tough time with the board
sabotaging me eat a whole
scotch but see i'm you see what you guys
done
no no i'm not doing it
that's it done get out of there get me
some more now now this is a mad team
i'm gonna die
someone called ambulance now
me
it's going to probably go on too anyway
it's set up to go on two
watch you're doing full fits bro pick
the full fit bro games change now this
is it we end the game on that bro
whole face off right now my stomach
hurts let number two
do the cinnamon challenge now let me
read huh let me read it that's the only
way i don't believe it so what you just
said what do you mean i know it don't
say that
do the cinnamon challenge you get me
that wasn't bring out the cinnamon
please i want to see this brother choke
the way you said look at the camera's
mad yeah because you need to let them
see you how are they going to know
what's going on
just swallow it
yeah drink it bro just
see the thing come at his nose did you
see that swallow just swallow blood
club i said he can't go calm oh calm
you're letting a bag in your ass blood
look careful try not to breathe too much
you're lucky thumb i can't believe you
got loud lucky that wasn't locked you
and i swallowed the cinnamon tea when i
found that one something to cough out
and spit everything easy
yeah his fans in it
yeah i knew it knew it was your time i
just knew it ah down to eggs you
chicken yeah bring out the eggs for this
brother man make sure the egg yolk's
dead as well want him to have the salt
eggs it is a bit bubbly though like
someone's spat in the glass but anyway
let's just go man that is light that's a
gym thing bro what do you mean come on
bow
swallow polo
he's a little bit that way
that is not the challenge
look at that
he's drinking it like it's a
alcohol juice and that's a bad boy's
spin see them spins there meant a lot to
me
one yes you're the last guy
that's you bro i don't know what's going
to happen go on oh fever look pic
love that
i want this one
eat a chunk of blue cheese yeah done
that's disgusting that cheese has gone
off by the way that oh show them at home
as well what about to eat bro all i've
got to do is just imagine that i've just
backed off some frank's hot sauce wings
tell me that ain't moldy bro
if i gave that to you and on your plate
and said yum that with the cheese and
rather than that than the egg what that
i know there's more juices for the gym
guys i know man back this egg i know
it's karma i know it's good for me but
he still still doesn't finish it bro
no just buy it a big bite oh my god he's
a trooper oh he's eaten blue cheese
before that bite said it all bro
oh that is disgusting man
lump it slump it my brothers don't eat
crumpets
man that t1 got away with murder today
you did you did get away with murder
[ __ ] what you say you got away murder
blood he's a savage yeah he ain't even a
savage he's a fish
he's in the sea he's doing a lot of
stuff he eats anything i hope you
enjoyed this one elvis full fit roulette
this has been t1
and this has been fishlish
and i've been your way over general over
and out love peace bro i'm not doing
this again with you because you're
[ __ ] awkward see you you don't want
to do nothing you don't want to do
nothing yeah but i didn't i don't know
where
you was dude wait wait wait stop stop
please